Nhanh dịch quân sự quái xoran nhằm và yvang vừa đô bộ chứng của Phòng Isoran Isoran Cá sết lộ.
Lạc các quả của quả chính trường bị kéo dạng nhiều tháng, bởi sự tham gia của cản dưới
quân sự và chính trị, Isoran và Mỹ.
Nãy tụi nâng in không choo em tư, các khởi hoạch tấn công đã được ban thảo ở nhiều cấp.
Tập chung và cơm mục tiêu hạp nhận chữ lợp, nhiều phó đầu, iso hàng và kế hoạch amse tinh nhảo
khoảng yvang.
Các quân học với bộ chứng của yvwing là gần phòng và Isoran cho thấy kế hoạch được chứ thành nhiều dạng.
Tương xây dừng dăng xanh mục tiêu hạp theo mục sát, đỏ, càng và sang lãn.
Một đỏ là chứ có kế hoạch amse sát, mổ cám là chubey, có mục săng là sẵn sẵn sẵn sẵn chín khai.
Trời đến việc năng mục sẵn sẵn chín đỏ theo tương mục lửa sân và sĩnh tập chính trình trình trường với Mỹ.
Tổng thống Trump, dù tổng sẵn sẵn sẵn sẵn sẵn sẵn xuân xuất quá trình trình Mỹ và tương xa lạnh hoán tình công và phút chất.
Ngay hai người thằng năm, ông Khá sva tụt tưởng Benjamin Tàn Già Húu đã chuyển i đẹp lên mức sẵn sàng Pê cộng bởi
tất không quan sẵn sẵn sẵn tấn tâm i ran trong một tôn.
Kế hoạch chiến khai không tích mấy hai ngày đã hế lộ những mức đi bài bản của Israel, kế thở với Mỹ, chất thấy sẵn trường bị kỹ lưỡng vấn nghiêm tốt,
trong một cuộc đối đau với Iran về bánh đệ hạp nhận.